the one role that i had to change the
most for
was probably baywatch
that movie i adopted a really really
specific eating regimen
and for zac efron that regimen took a
toll on his mental health the last thing
you want is to show up after training
that long and look flat very vein of us
but what what have they watched
the actor is the cover star for the
men's health october issue
and inside the bag he opens up about his
role in the 2017 film baywatch
where he endured intense training and
his abs were on full display i mean now
you're gonna have to beat me on the big
boys course princess
[Music]
and for zach he says that diet isn't
something he'd want to work towards
again quote that baywatch look i don't
know if that's really attainable there's
just too little water in the skin like
it's fake it looks cgi'd and that
required lasix powerful diuretics to
achieve so i don't need to do that i
much prefer to have an extra you know
two to three percent body fat
everything's functional we trained for
the parts we for this movie in
particular we like
we wanted to achieve a look and that
required a specific type of training and
that extreme regimen not only impacted
him physically but mentally as well
zack tells the mag i started to develop
insomnia and i fell into a pretty bad
depression for a long time something
about that experience burned me out i
had a really hard time recentering
ultimately they chalked it up to taking
way too many diuretics for way too long
and it messed something up that was the
most extreme i'd ever got and now zach's
in total control of his body and image
i guess the philosophy around my current
diet is intermittent fasting mixed with
getting enough nutrition to sort of
sustain me throughout the day i started
intermittent fasting just after i
stopped being vegan i feel good when i
have bananas and when i have sweet
potatoes oh and the hairspray star's
ultimate cheat meal i love to eat
massive amounts of pancakes
if i'm doing pancake day it's it's a lot
of pancakes
on top of fitness zach also reveals the
ways he's preparing himself to get back
into the dating game for him finding the
right person is all about timing quote
i've really been taking time to focus on
you know self-fulfillment and trying to
find my groove i know that probably when
i meet the right person it's going to be
when i least expect it
passed me like cooked for a date i
honestly can't even remember is that
that's that's terrible i think i'd leave
it to ordering
matlab and last meal i post made it for
a date
[Music]
you